i can give you just a few images
of flowers and tell you like these first
five are class a
the next five are class b and the last
five
i will just call them class c and by now
you had the time to look at them
i can give you a new one and ask you
what class is this and i'm pretty sure
almost all of you will answer correctly
now already
another one these are very different
images satellite images that you
may rarely see in your life actually but
still i'm gonna give you five and call
them class a
five other ones call them class b and
five other ones call them class c
and then again show you one this is
maybe a little bit less trivial than the
previous one but
i've talked a lot by now you know which
class this is already
and last one a bit more abstract
i'm gonna give you here six examples of
class a six examples of class
b and i'm gonna show you a new one
this depending on like your prior
thinking and so on
may require a little longer so i'm gonna
give you like five more seconds
by now you've looked at this looked at
that matched it and i'm pretty sure most
of you know what it is
uh if not this is class a because it's
only three objects in class bs6
but as you have seen your visual system
is pretty good at picking up new tasks
very different tasks
with just a few examples and this is
because of what your
visual system can already do like you
see this image you immediately see yeah
there's a bunch of boxes
shadows colors different materials and
so on right you have a
good preconceived vision system this is
what
we call what what we mean when we say
general visual representation you have a
good one in your brain and we're trying
to do the same
so okay this is the goal how do we
measure progress towards it
um a couple of years ago my team and i
we did the
what we call a visual task adaptation
benchmark uh which
provides the setting in which all of the
following things i'm going to talk
about i live in so there is this model
that comes from somewhere you have
trained somehow i don't really care
maybe it's on
hugging face hub and you can download it
or elsewhere and you can download it but
this model exists
right and now i want to test this model
how close is it to general visual
representation
then there is this landscape of all
reasonable visual tasks
and we proposed to basically sample some
and so we sampled 19 of them and each
task comes with
very few examples per class as a
training set
and a test set and now
you give me your model and you give me
an adaptation algorithm
and i apply this to each task
individually
all right adaptation algorithm does
whatever on
it once on this little training set and
then makes predictions on the test set
and i compute the average score and test
set and this is
your models and adaptation algorithms
meetup score
and we posit that by making progress on
this vitap score we make progress
towards the general visual
representation
um so this is the setting and the little
bit of nomenclature
this left side what you do to prepare is
called pre-training or sometimes
upstream
and this right-hand side is called
transfer sometimes downstream
right so this is the setting we operate
in and the goal we have
now how do we get there over the past
few years
we thought a few ways to get there
initially we thought ah self-supervised
pre-training that sounds really cool
there's like potentially infinite
images out there we could just train
visual knowledge from there without any
labels
um long story short we did some progress
on that
um published some papers but at the end
of the day we believe there is
always need for some labels somehow like
if you train
a couple models you need to choose one
at the end of the day somehow
and you need labels for that or if you
don't have labels
you look at what it predicts and say
yeah this is good is bad then
boom you just created labels um
so then we looked at semi supervisor
pre-training for a bit
with few labels and a lot of unlabeled
images it also works reasonably well
um but eventually we landed at large
scale supervised
free training where you pre-trained on
tons of images with some annotations and
this worked really well
and this set the ground for vision
transformer afterwards so i'm going to
dive a bit more into this large scale
supervised pre-training
and then going to talk all about vision
transformers
um all right so as i said
the images come from somewhere and there
is some information there that you can
transform into a label even though it's
not perfect
it can be a good enough label for
learning um and
at google we just happen to have this
large data set flying around there of
300 million images from the web
with some weak labels that were obtained
through some
process and so we use that and looked at
what can we get by pre-training models
on there and turns out that
by pre-training in the right way on this
huge data
we get huge wins like let's not care
about the details here but basically
state-of-the-art across
many vision tasks by pre-training a
resonant
on this but more surprisingly
we found one thing here x-axis is larger
model so to the right the model gets
larger
and the different curves are pre-trained
on different amounts of data green being
the least data
and orange being the most data and
here's the first surprising at least to
us finding
that for this few shot learning which is
the game i played with you before
the larger the model and the more data
it was print trained on
the better it performed there and
especially like the largest model on
most data
was really good another thing was
robustness we evaluated many different
ways robustness but this here is one
example of object net which is a data
set like imagenet but much more in the
wide as you can see here much more noisy
like chairs on beds
and stuff like that and same story here
the curves mean the same as previously
and the thing is
the largest model pre-trained on the
most data is just
ridiculously more robust than like
common models trained on common size
data without any extra tricks or
anything
so this was really good news um and this
set the ground to lag scale free
training
just gonna briefly it sounds easy right
lots of data
big model and that's it so i'm gonna
variably briefly go through a couple
little
details on why it was actually not
obvious at all to get there
um one thing was envision batch norm is
very widespread because it's in
resonance 50 and the resonant style
models and they are very widespread
this is regular training and testing
curves if you train resonate 50 on
imagine it looks good
throw in tons of data like 100 times
more data
and it looks like this the test clause
looks completely
crap and nothing works and it's unstable
turns out that after long searching the
culprit is batch norm
which has many issues but basically
after some digging we
propose to replace batch number group
norm and weight standardization and boom
we are back
in to the game uh but it's not the focus
of this talk why that is
and really really why we don't know
either we just have some hypothesis
another thing is that when you pre-train
you actually need patience
when you pre-train on lots of data here
this dot is the starting point of
standard training on imagenet
just using 10 times more data i'm not
changing anything else looks like it's
worse
but if you actually then train longer
and longer and longer then it gets
better and better and better
um just to show you how kind of
ridiculous this is
this is a training curve this is my
favorite plot ever
this is the training curve and this is
what it looks like if you look at the
small section of eight gpu weeks of
training that means eight gpus for a
week
or eight weeks on single gpu it looks
flat any reason every person would stop
and say yeah this is it we're done
but if you just are unreasonable and
keep training and keep training and keep
training
this is what the exact same curve looks
like then after a gpu month
and if you look at this you're seeing
yep consistent progress let's keep going
um and yeah let's keep that in the
interest of time
another thing is that you need to scale
both model and data set size together
if you have this blue dot which is
resonant 50
and you just train it on more images
going to the right it looks like it's
getting better
even more images and we're back to
getting it worse
but if you resonate 101 the same by the
way the green dot
but only when you get much bigger models
you see you keep seeing benefit for more
and more data
so that means large model lots of data
once you did that actually i'm not going
to go through details here but once you
did that in the pre-training
our transfer of fine tuning is really
simple it's just
take the pre-trained checkpoint sgd
momentum with a small learning rate
and you're done like no tricks no no
weight decay no residual adapters drop
out whatever
one trick in a sense that we use is from
a facebook paper it's called fix res
which is basically find unit higher
resolution
and they have lots of experiments and
justifications and so on but that works
pretty well um sometimes it makes up
all right so then we we basically
figured this out how to do large scale
pre-training and we got
this was the model we called a bit for
big transfer it was state of the art on
imagenet it was great
and then we were there and we thought
okay so
now we know how to do large scale
pre-training um
what next and basically in vision
convolution has been like the only name
in town since forever uh right
convenience everywhere
uh in language that was the case with
lstms or rnns
until transformer came and completely
changed everything convolutions seem to
fit very well image data
and rnns seem to fit very well
sequential data but then comes
transformer
which doesn't really seem to fit
sequential data better than
rnns but actually transformer and large
data
completely outperformed our enhancing
language so we wondered hmm
could this be the same could the same
happen in vision
and that let me introduce you to vision
transform which says yes
and the basic idea is super simple i'm
assuming that you already know
transformers in language at least
[Music]
in this case you take the image you cut
it into patches and each patch
of the image basically becomes a word in
the sentence you just
sequentially walk through the patches
each patch is a word you project them
into their embedding space
you add the position embedding you add
the
token for the class like the
end of sentence token in language then
you throw all of this through a big
transformer encoder
and then you extract from the class
token a classifier and predict the class
and this transform encoder is literally
just exactly the language transformer
from the original paper or from bird
even here the the layout base and large
are exactly the same as in
bird base and large and we also define
the huge which is a bit larger
the only new thing is what is your patch
size
and we denote this here with the slash
16. we usually take 16 pixels sometimes
32.
and then we do this whole thing that i
talked about previously this
pre-training on large data and then
transferring with this very simple
transfer recipe
and you've seen such a plot just before
with the
press
read this again but with the vision
transformer and it looks you know to
scale better
because in language this has been done a
lot scaling it up um and this works
it's got it's on a later slide it's got
sota everywhere too
um but then let's look a little bit
closer at these position embeddings
because i told you we just take the
patches walk through them
like through a sentence and that's it so
we completely
that they come in the layout and
the the position embeddings actually
learn this by them
where they are from so here each square
on the grid is one position embedding
and then each pixel in that cell is how
similar is it to these other position
embeddings
and as you can see the position
embeddings they recover this structure
of the grid layout where they are from
they are more similar to position
embeddings from nearby patches
we also did try like putting some 2d
information in the position embeddings
using relative position embeddings they
all basically perform the same
doesn't matter it just works to recover
positions just removing position
embedding still works but worse
um another interesting thing is the
receptive field size like if you have
the self attention you can look how far
does it attend to on average
and in the early layers of the network
we have some heads that
attend very far some heads that attend
only locally around them
and this slowly disappears and after
about half of the model's depth
we only have attention heads that attend
very far so i think so the model learns
to first compute more locally and then
later
only globally which is pretty cool we
just let it learn this from data
um and yeah like i said then with this
model
we got even better results on imagenet
again
and since as i said we know how to scale
division or transformers in general like
okay let's do it let's scale it even
further and that's how we're gonna go to
this
with g on the right and yeah that was a
recent paper of scaling up vision
transformers
so how do we get there okay first thing
is to just get more data
this is a bit boring more data better
but not that much if we don't change
anything else
now the question is how to scale up the
model and here we're going to talk a
little bit about tpus
you probably heard in the previous uh
presentation tpus really like multiples
of 128
and the title of the vision transformer
paper was an image is worth 16 by 16
words
so 256 words that's 2 times 128 that
makes tpu very happy
however i previously mentioned we add
this class token
which learns like what is the class and
so in reality we have 257
tokens there that makes tpu pretty sad
and it just
pads stuff left and right and it's it's
a waste
tpu's really don't like that so can we
get rid of this
that's what we looked at and luckily the
answer is yes this is actually
completely unnecessary
but it was just from us being as similar
as transformers in language but turns
out we can completely remove this
extra token just use global average
pooling or global max pooling in the
head it just works
or we can use a multihead attention
pooling as it was presented in
what was it set transformer paper i
think and that works they all work
equally well
but the multi-tension pulling is cool we
can imagine doing more things with it
down the road so we went for that one
and then we have
256 tokens actually which is very nice
for tpus
another thing is for scaling up for
scaling up memory is the most important
thing or the most
precious resource so we try to save it
where we can
and the vision transformers we train it
with adam and adam optimizer actually
needs
three times the model's size total
memory for the model parameters and
twice
for two different statistics for each
parameter
that's way too much basically
but like i said we can always look at
how do
language forks scale up transformers and
there was other factor optimizer
proposed which only needs the
other meters
in memory then some very small overhead
however if we just apply this to vision
transformers it simply doesn't work so
we
had a little bit of time digging into it
we found that eventually we found that
we need to reintroduce the momentum term
but we can store it in half precision we
need to disable some automatic learning
rate scaling that's part of other factor
and likes a few such small tweaks and
then other factor works very nicely and
matches the training curves of adam
almost perfectly but with half the
memory overhead so great we just cut our
memory usage in half
means we can make the model larger
and now here's another thing about jacks
and
tpus in general it's a compiler so it
compiles your model and it has lots of
optimization passes
which try really hard to
to let your model run so they try to do
automatic
gradient checkpointing and things like
that to save memory if you ask it to run
a large model
so that means you can barely predict if
the model will fit or not
um even if you look at the free memory
it you might fit more than what was free
before
uh so basically what we do is run lots
of
vision transformers in lots of different
settings here we have
each square is one model setting then we
have the width of the mrp
the number of layers across the plots
and the width of the self attention
on the height and a color means it fits
orange means the original vision
transformer paper setting
and here i marked the layout of with l
and with h from the original paper
and then in green and in blue with the
memory saving improvements that i talked
about earlier we can fit a lot more
and so we select some model here
not completely arbitrarily but more or
less on gut feeling we know that's which
need to scale everything a bit
and run this as the largest model you
can see some holes here these are not
bugs these are actual situations
where the compiler manages to fit a
larger model but not the smaller one
that happens sometimes basically to know
what fits you actually need to try to
run it
with objects and views
all right let me skip this uh it's
pretty cool but
in the interest of time uh another thing
we
noticed there or introduced is um
you can get a lot of win on future
learning
on this uh v-top setting that i told you
earlier
um if you sacrifice a bit of the
pre-training performance
or upstream performance as we say here
um
by using different weight decay for the
head then for the rest of the model
so apply large weight decay for the head
and small weight decay for the rest of
the model
this makes your pre-training performance
look worse
so you might think you have a worse
model but actually the representation
that it learns is better
and performs much better in q-shot
learning
the intuition behind this is if you
think back at svms
in svm you add the weight decay in order
to increase the margin
between the classes and we believe
there's similar thing going on here if
we
have a highway decay on the head we ask
the representation that
comes into the head to have a larger
margin and this larger margin then makes
eventually fusion learning
work better all right taking all of
these things together
uh we get a really good vision
transformer model this is with g
this giant model that i showed you with
all of these tricks this dotted line
is the previous vision transformer in
from the original edition transformer
paper
and here we have another couple uh
popular
models that are pretty good at few shots
which is seem clear
and violent these are two
self-supervised methods
um and it is actually pretty amazing
with just 10
examples per class on imagenet this vg
gets 85 percent upon accuracy with just
a linear classifier on top
just doing linear regression nothing
else um
yeah so this is cool um
however a few more things are cooler
than the sota i think or a few more
insights here
um the first one these three plots are
essentially the same they're just
different ways to measure
like how good is the representation so
just look at one is enough ignore the
others
pick your favorite one then the three
different curves
are three different vision transformers
of
different sizes the blue one is the
smallest one it's tiny
and the orange one is the largest one
it's air
and so we see here on the x-axis how
many images
it has seen during pre-training how many
different images from 100 to 10
in millions from 100 million to 3
billion i think
and what we see here is that actually
the large model
performs much better on the y-axis
better lower is better
it's the error rate so large model
performs much better after seeing much
fewer images
than small model and it it's like almost
two orders of magnitude here
of difference and this is kind of
counterintuitive or at least it was for
us
that a large model is better even after
seeing fewer images than a small model
so this again speaks for large models in
pre-training
we also found that there are scaling
laws that are already well known in
language domain for transformers
we also see them in the vision domain
basically uh so
transformer performance is pretty
predictable
once we have this good pre-training
setup um
okay so this was all cool but this is
not useful for majority of people
because nobody has three billion images
lying around right nobody can train
forever on
huge models so then we ask the question
how
would you train your vit if you don't
have these things
and we investigated this uh quite in
depth in another recent paper that is
called how to train you of it
and i'm just going to give you the few
tidrs
out of that the first one is kind of
obvious in hindsight at least
and diet also already hinted in that
direction too is that basically if you
add data augmentation and model
regularization
or greg just for sure um
then into your pre-training procedure
and you can get quite a boost
and basically your large data set
plus or greg then gives you a model that
performs similarly than a 10 times
larger data set
and so the largest that i know
public image data set that is good for
pre-turning is imagenet 21k
and so you add the auger egg to this in
the right way and boom you have a model
that is
a vision transformer that is similarly
good to the
jft 300 million private dataset
pre-trained one
um but the nice thing is this is our
public so we can actually release these
checkpoints and we recently
like just a week or two ago i don't
remember release these checkpoints they
are now
available um but then
most people don't want to do this
pre-training but actually have their
data set up interest that has maybe like
3 000 or 30 000 images
so we picked a bunch of data sets like
this that we took as a
representative of what uh some
practitioner might want to do
right correct your data set of your very
specific application
but then it's not going to be in the
millions of images but in the thousands
or ten thousands
and then we wanted to compare from
scratch training and the transfer
with transfer being the setting that we
proposed from the start
and from scratch we spent a lot of time
on the from scratch training
adding augmentations regularizations
different training settings and so on
and we got all of these blue points each
one is a model
trained on that data set again lower is
better
because y-axis shows error right so you
can get
reasonably good on on the medium large
data set by spending a lot of
time and adding lots of augmentations
regularizations
however if you just take the model
pre-trained on imagenet 21k
the vision transformer and just do this
very simple transfer
recipe that i mentioned before which is
sgd momentum
fine tuning with the smaller learning
rates and no other special tricks
then you get these dark green points
they are
just so much better especially for the
small data set
and you get them in so much less
training time that it's
in my mind it's a no-brainer that if you
want to actually do something in
practice you would use pre-trained
models and transfer them
there is another question what if you
add augmentation regularization during
transfer
these are all the half transparent
points here um
so you can hit a lot of bad settings
actually if you are lucky you can hit
even better settings but in my opinion
not really worth the search
all right there there's a few more
insights but just
a small one if you're interested in
small models
um here we show that
increasing the patch size is actually
better to get good small models
than making the model smaller here we
have tiny model
with 16 by 16 patch size is much worse
than
equally fast base model with 32 by 32
patch size
this is the thing the community seems to
have ignored and everybody has settled
on 16 but that's really bad
for small models um
right so all of these are now available
by now already in the vision transformer
repo and the pie torch team
repo um hugging phase
have vision transformers but not yet the
i believe not yet the how to train your
bit
models um but yeah we released all the
models this was a large study
and there are 50 000 vision transformer
checkpoints that you could
look at investigate or not um
i had another section on whether we are
done with imagenet or not
but i will skip it in the interest of
time
so i can take a few questions just check
out
this paper if you are interested the
answer is like it's complicated yes
all right but i'm gonna stop here
awesome thank you so much luca uh super
impressive to see
that scale and the results um amazing
we have actually a lot of questions in
the chat we don't have
a lot of time to go through all of them
um but maybe we can take one or two at
least
uh maybe uh one thing uh at the very
beginning
uh someone asked if there is like a rule
of thumb for
parametrization versus data set size
complexity for vision models
uh yeah i think so we didn't really do
this
here but i looked a little bit at it um
i think you can probably figure out some
kind of scaling rules that relate model
size
computes that you have available and the
eventual performance
and data assuming infinite data for
example but we didn't
do it all the way here because we ran
out of time and
for regularization actually i have a
slide that i'm skipping here but in the
how to train your bit
we actually try to map out the landscape
of like
what works for what model size and there
are some surprises but that i skipped
here
um for example
augmentation is almost always good but
regularization is not
almost always good and whether it's good
or not depends on model size and data
set size exactly you should check out
this
how to train you read paper for that one
nice thanks and maybe one
more of the later questions um
let's see do you think the inductive
bias
of assuming sequential data is crucial
to the cross-domain success of
transformer
for instance could you still find
success in vision if you chose a random
way
to provide patches
yeah as long as it's consistent right
actually
the patches that the vision transformer
sees
it we don't tell it which ones are
neighbors
actually here it doesn't really know
that this one is to the left of that one
and so on
um but because we consistently always
give them in the same order
then it can eventually over time learn
it and that's kind of what we
try to show here that the position
embeddings actually
recover or learn it from the data
themselves what
what comes from where um so
yeah i don't think that the linearity of
the data is
important in transformers
awesome thanks so much i think we'll
move to the second talk i don't know if
you have like a few more minutes
um to stick with us there's like a bunch
more questions i'll try to make the
the chat history afterwards available
anonymize it and make it available if
you
have time to have a look at one or two
more questions that would be awesome
yeah i can scroll through a few
questions now and answer them in the
chat also
nice thank you so much great talk um
perfect i think we can maybe move on to
the second talk of the day
um ben if you're ready um feel free to
unmute yourself and slide and share your
slides yes
perfect um yeah the second talk is going
to be by ben wang while you're
setting up your slides who is an
independent ai researcher
and you're contributing to a luther ai
which is also very exciting
which many of you know is an open source
research collective centered around
democratizing access to very
big ai models very large scale language
models
among others and yeah very excited to
hear your talk and
yeah yeah so kind of the overall topic
of what we'll be talking about today is
specifically
some of the aspects and kind of
challenges with
scaling up training to multiple hosts
in this new transformer library called
mesh transformer jacks which
i wrote so yeah first i guess before we
start we can talk a little bit about
blue there you go
so it's a grassroots ai research group
that's kind of organizes around a
discord server
that's got a heavy focus on scaling as
well as democratizing
these large amounts and some notable
works that you might have seen before
one includes the pile which is a 800
gigabyte data set
of diverse text for language modeling
it's constructed to be similar to
opening eyes data for gpthree but more
diverse
so it includes a lot of data sets
including github
pubmed common crawl offset etc
um yeah and kind of interesting is that
the inclusion of git up means that all
these
models that have been released by obese
era are actually quite good at
writing code which is pretty
pretty cool given github copilot and
things like that
shows that that is quite a uh
interesting use case
um yeah and another one that's been
released is gpt neo
which is a mesh tensorflow based
transform implementation
uh and that has 1.3 billion and 2.7
billion
models released and kind of the topic of
this talk is mesh transformer jacks
which is a
jax based modern parallel transformer
implementation
and this has a six billion parameter
model uh
released which is trained on the pile as
well uh and the model is called gptj6b
um yeah and to talk a little bit more
about the model uh it's a 6.1 billion
parameter
autoregressive language model it's also
trained on the pile like all the other
ones
and it has comparable performance to the
gpd 3
6.7 billion version uh it's trained with
mesh transfer jacks it has fully open
source code and weights under the
apache 2.0 license and it performs
eight-way megatron lm style model
parallelism
um i'll talk a little bit more about
that later
um yeah and it's trained on a tpu v3 256
for about four weeks uh and there is
hugging face
slash support um in a pull request but
it hasn't been merged yet
hopefully that'll go through soon so i
guess yeah
you can you can use it through hiding
face um
yeah and kind of the i guess the middle
of the talk
would be so first we'll talk about
um kind of the jack's programming model
across multiple
hosts as well as multiple devices which
is a spmd model
which stands for a single program
multiple data
and then we'll talk a bit about the
design philosophy of kind of
this code base as well as as well as the
overall architecture
then we'll talk about the design
challenges specific to
training across multiple hosts including
code distribution
and data loading and then we'll talk
about some future directions
uh which includes swarm training
yeah so the jax spmd programming model
on a single tpu um basically means that
when you parallelize
code to run between the cores all the
cores must run the exact same
code uh so when i say parallelizing code
that that means a lot of different
operators which includes
pmap xmap pgi like all of these
operators they rely on
around this assumption essentially so
we can do a simple example of a female
computation
so we created input which is uh just
number zero to three and then we run a
pmap computation which would
square each number and to see how this
would actually get executed so this is a
hypothetical
four caller tpu it doesn't exist as far
as i know
uh but it'll be too difficult to draw
more holes in this so in
the first line that runs the input
equals jmp dot arrange
four that actually creates variables
that
are that just lie on the first tpu core
essentially
um so um yeah
so you have the the the four numbers and
they all lie on the first two people
and then when you get into the pmap
computation the first thing that happens
in the computation is that it would
actually shard the inputs so it would
uh place each uh part of the array
on a separate chord and then you have
your pmap computation that runs
which runs across all the cores uh it
must be the same
uh and then the outputs you get returned
and that gets returned
it kind of looks like a single array um
but it's actually a class called shutter
device array uh which means that
kind of each uh element of the array
actually lies on a different core
um so you can kind of interact it
interact with it as if it was a single
array but like
it actually but like the backing store
for that array
is sharded um so i mean this seems
relatively straightforward on a single
tpu but when you try to scale up to
multiple uh tpus on a tpu pod
it gets a little bit more complicated so
a tpu pod it looks very similar to just
multiple tpus
here we have two four core tp hosts um
and they are you know exactly the same
but the only difference is that they
have a different host
index so the first core that's right the
first host has host index zero the
second host has
his index one um and the the
assumption still needs to hold that when
you parallelize code between the nodes
all the chords will still run doesn't
occur so
i guess we can try to do another p-map
computation
uh similar to the first one so
uh here we have the same line of code
from before at jmp range
four black hat doesn't do the right
thing um because
it will have the array of zero to four
that's right zero to three on the first
post as well as zero to three on the
second post
um so what you need to do is you
actually need to do something based on
the host index
so in this case uh we would add host
index times four
which would mean that the first host has
the number zero to three on it the
second post has numbers
uh four to seven uh and then you have
this kind of virtual array that is zero
to seven
and then you do the same pm computation
um
and this python code must be run on all
the tpu
hosts on the pod and if you do that and
this is what it looks like
so you have the same you know uncharted
inputs as before
uh except that so so kind of each
host looks at like one part
so it looks like it it looks at one part
of the inputs
that gets distributed to the local tpu
tpu cores
and then the same the similar process
for sharing the inputs happens but when
the inputs get sharded
it actually happens across the whole tp
pod and then so does the pmac
computation
so uh yeah and when
the outputs get returned we have
something similar
but kind of each tpu like on http host
you only see a part of the output you
only see the part of the output that
corresponds
to the cause on the ttp first
so the first host sees zero to
or sees the first four elements the
second host sees the second
four elements um
yeah so kind of this is basically how
you can scale
above just eight tpu cores uh you can go
to to a lot more
um yeah so now we'll move a little bit
into talking about how
mesh transformer jacks is designed so
kind of
the most important design philosophy is
i did not want to spend too much time
running it so it was to minimize the
developer hours
uh for writing the framework and for
kind of producing this artifact of a
large model
so this code base is quite simple the
total code for model training
is only about a thousand minus code uh
which
compared to things like megatron is like
about an order of magnitude
us um and there's some
other stuff like model evaluation model
inferencing and things like that which
make about the total uh code about 2000
as a code
um and kind of because this is only
going to train a few models
uh for both the works of abstraction
so there's very few
like options for these different models
and there's quite a few
high parameters uh for a lot of them i
just picked as
default and just ran it at that
so it's mostly simple straight line code
there's no
nothing crazy going on um so yeah that
means like trying to models might make
it so
complicated um and another one
kind of stunts on the the other two is
that's simplicity
uh often is better over scalability
so it has a very simple uh parallelism
scheme
which is similar to the original
megatron lm
and what that does essentially is
the hidden dimension gets uh replicated
across all the devices
but kind of the feedball dimension and
the heads
are sharded across the devices
so that kind of minimizes the amount of
monoparallel
communication you need compared to
some other approaches and there's kind
of no
really exotic optimizations it's just
very simple
um monoparallel and data parallel
um computation so you know there's no
no such thing like we don't do zero or
python parallelism
or anything uh crazy
so kind of given this philosophy this is
the architecture that we
came up with so uh first you have a
bunch
of tpu hosts so like when you create a
uh
a tpu product this is what you get you
get uh
for or in this case uh but
up to like 32 or even more uh tv hosts
and between the tpu hosts there is a
high speed networking
uh there's a high speed network that
connects all the tpus
and that's where the model parallel data
parallel communication
happens um and then we also have a
separate driver
virtual machine which is a google cloud
cloud vm that's on the same region in
the same zone
as these tpu hosts and it kind of does
coordination
so it um it kind of talks to all the
other tp hosts it uses rpc calls
so it essentially can call remote
functions on the tpu hosts
and this essentially allows everything
to happen on the same order
on all the tv hosts so the driver van
makes sure that you know if it
if it runs a training step on one host
it runs it on every other host
so that kind of maintains the invariant
that all the that all the hosts
and all the callers run all the same
code
and the library that was used for these
rpc calls was
ray seems to work quite well um
yeah pretty pretty fast low overhead and
it scales
at least up to the pod sizes that
i've been doing
yeah so this seems somewhat
straightforward
but there are some challenges kind of
unique to this multi-host
training system um so the first is that
uh you know every code must run the same
computation uh rpc helps a little bit
with that
by making sure everything runs in the
same order but kind of
how does the actual code get to the the
virtual machines
get to the tpu host
and then you also have the challenge
that every node needs to see different
data
so how does this data get distributed um
yeah so the first thing uh would be
the code distribution so um it's kind of
problematic you have to like install
dependencies you must have the same
versions
and you also must just copy the code to
all the nodes so
a obvious question is where you actually
copy it from
uh do you do it from like github or like
your local machine um like where does it
come from
um and you also must be able to scale it
too many nodes
so the the v3 256
has 32 host nodes um that's quite a few
but not
that many but if you wanted to scale to
something
bigger uh like a 2048
uh that's hundreds of host nodes so um
if it's slow your training will take a
long time
to start um so what i
ended up going with was um kind of
looking at
this problem as kind of like a
orchestration problem and there are
existing tools for doing that
uh you know for example shell scripts
kubernetes docker etc
and kind of there's a general trend with
these tools that as you get more robust
you also get
less uh simple you get more complex um
so i decided to go with you know
simplicity
over robustness uh because
uh like if i'm doing if there's only
one training run going on it's not like
if it breaks i can
fix it um and there's
the uptime of the training isn't the
most important
um so you know we have shell scripts
that
install dependencies uh and scp
that copies code from the local
directory to other vms
so yeah pretty pretty simple setup
and with data loading um there are some
other challenges with this as well
so first is shuffling um so
yeah when you are training these large
models it's very important to make sure
that
the um that the data is shuffled
at both a document level as well as um
the context window level so kind of when
you
if you only shuffle at the document
level
then and if you have like really long
documents
um that could mean your uh kind of batch
is just near one document which is
really
really bad for for for convergence as
well as for stability
so it's very important to make sure
shuffling is done well
another thing is that resume must be
implemented efficiently
so i was training on preemptable
tv pods so that means you know every
every few every few hours the uh the tpu
pod would
with preempt and i'll have to restart
the training uh
from from a checkpoint so um it's it's
important that resume is efficient
and fast because if it's slow then a lot
of your time will actually be spent
resuming from a checkpoint rather than
training
so it's um so with
some solutions like tf data it's
actually hard to resume without re
without reading like a significant
fraction of all the data that you've
trained on previously
um it might not be a big issue with
things like
um images uh where with image status
that's where you do like
a lot of epochs but here you only do one
epoch
so uh you know you have to read
terabytes of
of stuff to kind of get to the same spot
and then you also have the chlorination
challenge of how you make sure that no
two hosts train on the same data
because if they do then you're kind of
wasting a lot of your compute
so what we decided to go with is so
first we have this
um like very similar architecture from
before
uh driver vm uh to the tp hosts rpc
number three
um so the first decision i was made was
actually to
read the data uh to do the data loading
on the driver vm
and to distribute it to all the hosts so
that means there's only kind of a single
there's kind of only a single process
that is doing the data
loading and it reads tf record files
from um google cloud storage buckets
so um shuffling is done
um kind of before all this so it's not
even kind of in this code base
so it's important to do like a per
document and per sequence
uh pre-shuffle um and because you're
only doing one epoch it makes it quite
quite easy you don't really have to
worry about um
kind of reshuffling between ebooks you
can just kind of go through
the tf records one by one so there's a
index file
which contains or contains htf record
and then it kind of just perfectly
sequentially goes through all these tf
records
so it goes um through
the list of tier records and with an htf
record it goes um
it goes through each example
sequentially
so what that means is as long as you
save which report you were reading
and uh how far you were through it all
you need you only need to
kind of read through one tf record uh so
that's
uh you know only a very small fraction
of your total
training data and kind of the driver vm
also
handles it also makes sure that it
distributes data evenly it doesn't send
the same data to
uh multiple tpu hosts and
this seems to work quite well i think
overall
the data learning challenges are not too
significant for at least these text
models
i don't think this architecture would
work very well for vision models for
example
it works well for text models because
the input and output data rates are so
low uh on the order of hundreds of
kilobits per second
that you don't really need to worry
about making this too efficient
so simple so something simple just
works well yeah and i guess next i can
talk about some
some future possible future directions
um so kind of
uh all um
all the stuff that's been talked about
um for now has been
uh you're training on a single big tpu
pod
um however smaller tpu pods it's usually
easier to get capacity
on um so the question is how do you
combine multiple tpu parts into one
training run so you know you have some
other possible
possible complexities you can have
heterogeneous parts so you can have a
mix of a2 v3 tpus
and you can and these pods would also be
preemptable so any node can go down
at any time so this is kind of a quite a
difficult challenge um so one
way of approaching this is fault
tolerant data parallelism
uh there's this paper uh that was
actually by
some people from hogging face which
essentially does data parallelism um
and um just does a kind of fault
tolerant
or reduce of the gradients at the end of
each step
um but here kind of the problem is that
the model size
that you can use is limited by the size
of the smallest device
um that might not matter too much for um
if you're doing small models but for
kind of these like really big
uh you know multi-billion parameter
models
it does make a
it is quite a challenge so kind of the
smallest
um device that um that the gpt j6b
training would fit on is a uh eight core
v3 pod
um and it would not fit on a 8 or v2 pod
so you would need kind of
so like the unit of pod you get must be
pretty
pretty big especially as you're
considering even larger models
and then another approach is pipeline
parallelism
so that's kind of i've been working on
that in a separate repository called
swarmjacks
and also cohere they might talk about
this um
it's um yeah they'll be talking
uh they'll be the last top of the day i
think
so yeah um i think kind of these
uh so both these approaches are pretty
promising
um and i think some something like that
would be
necessary for efficiently training large
models
in the future so yeah that's
i have thanks for um listening
uh happy to answer some questions
very cool thank you so much uh great
work interesting architecture and also
to see like the
design philosophy and the design choice
assuming
pretty cool we have a few questions uh
maybe let me start with the first one
on top what exactly is a one epoch what
exactly is one epoch regime
right uh yeah so so one epoch basically
means you just go through
all the data once uh rather than kind of
training multiple times on the
of the data um so that's
kind of uh i guess one epoch regime is
is pretty specific to just large
language models i don't know anyone
else does that um because kind of with
language models it's quite easy to get
large amounts of text
and each token is quite um
and each token is quite expensive
computation
wise so it's easy enough to get
enough data such that you only have the
compute to do one h
we have uh two related more general
questions how many people worked
concurrent or work concurrently on
on the project and implementations and
what does mesh and mass transformer
refer to
yeah um so the the code
uh on this was written uh entirely by
me um and another contributor um
aaron he uh kind of helped with the
hyperparameter
and some debugging uh the
the mesh in mesh transformer kind of uh
is i think it's it comes from like the
comes from mesh tensorflow i guess um
and
that comes from the kind of how
like like the way that um that
these uh these arrays are distributed
across the uh
um are across the tpu so
um yeah kind of uh
it's like a um
yeah so i think it's something like like
that i guess
cool and um maybe the last question is i
can see now
is the data loading pipeline fully
reproducible given preemptions if not
have you thought about whether it could
be done efficiently
yeah so the data loading is fully
reproducible
um there's
basically you save like how many batches
you are through htf records
and which tf record you are you are at
and that allows you to perfectly
reduceably uh do this i think most of
the reproducible
reproducibility challenges um comes from
the
shuffling step and because here we don't
actually do any shuffling in this
repository
it makes it quite easy i think that's
the
yeah very cool and that was the last
question
so thank you so much again ben um super
interesting work and
um yeah i think we can maybe
move on to the third talk of today
um i think our speaker should be all
here
right now let me just double click yes
i'm here
perfect i think sonia is also here
and you just make johnny hook
unviewed
okay i've just shared my screen can you
see it yes looks good i'm just checking
in with johnny huck if uh
if everything works
on this side
you should be able to unmute yourself i
think or
yeah i think i'm admitted okay
perfect sonja should be also
ready right perfect okay uh nice so i
think we can start with the third talk
i'm very excited to welcome yuri kimaev
sonia mokora and jun hugo
from deepmind and to hear about the
deepline jax ecosystem
yeah thanks for the introduction so my
name is yuri
and together with sonia and juniuk we're
going to tell you about how we use jax
at deepmind
um i'm starting with our deepmind jax
ecosystem
which is essentially a collection of
jacks libraries that we have been
developing over the last
two years um so
why an ecosystem um well
deepmind researchers have had great
initial success with jax in its early
days
and the question that naturally arose is
how can we continue to support and
accelerate this great initial work
and there are a few considerations that
we took into account
when kind of making decision about
creating an ecosystem
um the first of which is that jax is not
a vertically
integrated machine learning framework
but rather
a set of very powerful and flexible
trans function transformation for
example grad and pmap
which gives us a huge freedom a great
freedom to implement
a variety of tools on top of it to
basically support our
rapidly evolving requirements um
besides we really want new tools to be
consistent and compatible with
the previously realized released
frameworks like
sonnet and truffle from from the
tenderloin land
um so to accomplish this and other goals
we we decided to
develop an ecosystem
of libraries of reusable independent and
unopinionated jax components and
under reusable here i mean that
this should be flexible at first
they should be up to date and have a low
entry threshold
independent means that they can nicely
integrate with each other but more
importantly can be used
seamlessly in separation and
unopinionated means that they are not
biased towards
any concrete approach or paradigm to
basically be able to quickly
implement new ideas and
basically contribute them back into into
community
and each library is intended to do one
thing
really well and it supports incremental
buy-in and
we'll see some examples in the next
slide last but
certainly not least we are open sourcing
everything
to basically enable research idea
sharing and to ensure that
the results obtained using this
library and this ecosystem are
reproducible
outside of deepmind so in the next few
slides i will show you three examples of
the libraries
that that are part of the ecosystem
um and we're starting with haiku
haiku is the library for neural networks
and
the motivation behind it goes down to
the facts to the fact
that um much of the power objects
comes from the functional programming
paradigm uh whereby we have
functions that are stateless or pure and
we have
different function transformations that
produce another pure stateless function
that can be applied to any kind of
numerical data
like tensors however
like the common abstractions in
the machine learning area for example
trainable neural network parameters or
neural network states
think of edge norm state
fits potentially a bit better to
the object-oriented paradigm or at least
this is how people are
used to think about it so haiku kind of
bridges the gap between these two worlds
between the world of object-oriented
programming and the world of functional
programming
by providing a set of tools to convert
stateful functors
such as neural networks into
init and apply pure function
basis function hence they can be used
directly in jacks
um and our researchers had had a great
success with
to really reporting the previous results
um from tensorflow
such as antastar and alpha fold into the
jacks world
yes so this library is stable mature
and it's widely adopted within deep
minds and google and the public
community as well
as well as the other examples so the
next example is optics
optics is for optimization and
optimizers are also
playful mostly and as haiku bridges the
gap
between objects oriented paradigm and
the functional paradigm for neural
networks
effectively does it for optimizers
um and one crucial observation here
is that basically things like adam
momentum
and i know lgd can be implemented as
a chain operator of simple
um creating processing primitives and
this is these are the first things that
optics implements and then using this
primitive
it kind of provides a zoo of
of the common optimizers that that
people know
use and love
and of course obviously users are free
to use this primitives to implement
their own optimizers their own
transitional algorithms and try out new
ideas
so optics nicely integrates into place
with haiku but more importantly
its scope is much wider and it can be
seamlessly integrated into common
common jacks neural network libraries
such as
flags and eventually in anything that
represents
parameters as a tree of tensors
so the last example for today is relax
and
as you may know deepmind cares quite a
lot about reinforcement playing
and one well-known complexity of it is
that
it's quite easy to get things wrong uh
for example if you place top gradient in
the wrong place
um that can completely jeopardize your
whole research effort
um in a sense that you will still be
observing
somewhat meaningful and probably even
interesting
yet completely delusive results um and
it can take some time it can take some
significant amount of time to
detect this kind of fears and the idea
behind relax
is to provide a collection of
trusted and battle-tested components for
building reinforcement learning
algorithms that are common common for
them um
and for example on the right hand side
you can see how
two of such primitives that is q
learning and square laws
can be combined to define a loss
function that
that you might want to use in your q
learning algorithm
and in case of relax a lot of emphasis
was put on
readability um so if you look at the dog
strings
of relax you will find actual excerpts
from the textbooks um with conventional
reinforcement link notation and
this are intended to be self-explanatory
basically
um okay so i
i'm afraid i don't have enough time to
cover all the libraries that
can that constitute the
jack sticker system today um but there
are definitely more
for example we have giraffe to library
for graph neural networks processing
checks for debugging testing reliability
and we have this tracks for mastering
probability distributions
which is fully compatible with
tensorflow probability for example and
in in fact they're interoperable in the
jack fans
um plus we have few few more that are on
our roadmap
and we will probably release soon um
it's worth mentioning that
there's another separate layer of
frameworks built on top of the checks
with the system
um both within the declines uh within
deepmind such as jet signs and acme
and outside the deepmind such as flags
jacksonville and jax cam
so i highly encourage you to check them
out
for more details also there is a blog
post
about with a nice overview of the
existing libraries we have
at deepmind.com and yeah
that's that's it from me with with this
i think the rest of this
part of the talk um chen yuk and sonia
will
tell you about their research which is
based on jax and jack's ecosystem
and basically yeah
with this over to you sona
hello i hope that you
can hear me and see me
um oh great um
yeah so yeah uh hello everyone
my name is sonia and i will talk a bit
about what makes jax great for
generative models
specifically for guns
next slide please
uh okay so uh generative adversarial
networks or guns
are a bit different to many other more
standard generative models
uh as they don't follow the paradigm of
one model one loss
in guns we have two players uh there is
the generator
which produces the data and there is a
discriminator
which has to distinguish the real data
from the generated data
uh they and these two players compete
with each other
uh so the discriminator really wants to
be as good as possible in knowing
when data is real when it's fake uh and
the generator tries to fool the
discriminator
into thinking its creations are from the
real data set
there are multiple ways to implement
this which we are not going to discuss
but the key point is that we have two
players playing against each other
hence the name adversarial next slide
please
okay so uh one thing that we might want
to do when implementing a gun
uh is to have multiple discriminator
updates for a single generator update
uh or maybe the other way around but i
think this is usually done
this is really easy in jax because you
just write a single for loop for the
discriminator updates
and a separate for loop for the
generator update
and choose however many iterations you
want in each of them
let's look at the example of the
discriminator update in the slide
so that's the first that's the first
block uh
you can see that we've wrapped the
discriminator loss with the jegs grab
method
and then evaluate it at the current
values of the discriminator and
generator parameters
so the graph method returns as the full
gradient function
so not just the values but the actual
function
and this is a gradient with respect to
the first argument
so in this case this would be the
discriminator parameters
so notice that there is no need to stop
the gradient
to the generator parameters or anything
like that uh
because the way like because the
gradient functions
works like this like it will
differentiate with respect to the first
parameter the first argument uh we know
that that's just the discriminator
parameters and it doesn't matter that we
then evaluate it using generated
parameters
um uh yeah looking at it the the next
step that you do is that you
explicitly pass the gradients to your
optimizer's update function
and then you apply the updates to get
the new parameters
and then for the generator you do
exactly the same thing so
but this time you use the generator loss
and you can see that this generator loss
takes the generator parameters as the
first argument
so we know that the gradient gradient
will be taken with respect to the
generator parameters this time
and that means that you are going to
update the generator this time
only uh notice that the code looks
very similar to what a pseudocode would
look like for gun right like
it's a get a gradient evaluated
update like apply the updates so
i think this is quite neat that
basically it makes the code very
clean and easy to read and understand
next slide please
ah thank you uh so one more thing to
highlight
about this is that uh we have direct
access to the gradients
so they are not just hidden somewhere uh
if we want to somehow track them
for example we might want to see uh what
the norm
of the gradient looks like at different
layers uh we can do this very easily
because the
values are available to us uh we can
just add a couple of lines of
numpy that we are all like mostly
familiar with
and then just log the statistics in a
way that we find useful
and yeah this is this is very important
because tracking
statistics like this uh helps a lot in
building intuitions
about what our models are actually doing
so yeah i think it's really nice and
cool that
you can do it very easily without much
additional work in jacks
next slide please
um so another thing that is
quite natural in jax is that jax gives
you
direct control and makes you think about
some decisions
that you have to make uh instead of just
making these decisions
under the hood without you even
realizing that something
something's happening uh so for example
uh let's talk about this like when
you're updating the discriminator
uh what should you do about the state of
a generator
and by state i don't mean the parameters
this time i mean
uh more something like for example batch
norm statistics for the
for the generator uh so yeah do we want
to update these two
uh yeah let's not talk about what we
actually want to do in guns
uh the key point is that it's a thing
you might want to
think about and decide consciously about
instead of letting the framework do the
work
uh in this slide oh you can see that we
are sampling from the generator
we are passing in this stated gen
variable
which is the original state value of the
state in generator
and this function is returning us a new
value for this which we are saving in a
gen state variable and
then at the end of this method we are
returning the two states the
discriminative generator state
and we decided to return the new value
of the state
uh alternatively if we decide that we
actually don't want to update the
generator state
next like this yeah so so this is very
easy
you just don't use it meaning when you
are calling the sample method
you use the state.gen to pass it there
and you just ignore whatever is returned
and when it comes to returning from this
method you just return the original
value
of the state.gen so this way you know
that
the generator state is not going to get
updated just because you know that
you ignored the value for the update so
it's it will not be used
um okay now next slide please
uh yeah so this is the last thing i
would like to point out
uh which in related relation to guns
so we often use this re-parametrization
trick
in guns which is a thing that
sometimes we need to differentiate with
respect to parameters
of a distribution that we sample from so
you can see that there is this expected
value
um and usually we would estimate this
expectation for example by
sampling multiple times from this
distribution
and this is a problem it's quite
difficult to differentiate
uh random random like things that are
random
so instead if we can uh we will try to
change the parameters
in a way that the randomness gets
extracted out to a separate variable
and which is no longer dependent on the
parameters
so this might be a bit confusing but i
don't know think about
instead of sampling from a normal
distribution with some
mean and variance uh we will sample from
a standard normal
and then we will just multiply by sigma
and add the mean
so now the stigma and mean are sort of
separate from
the part where we are sampling
uh and yet what is the example here is
showing how to calculate the jacobian in
such a case
of a reparametrist a reparametrized
function and what is nice about doing
these injects
is that we can vectorize our function
very easily
so the function f uh maybe if it's a
neural network maybe it's very
like trivial to vectorize it but it
doesn't have to be a neural network it
might be something more complicated
and yeah we don't have to rewrite it at
all we can just use this
jacks.vmap and wrap it around our
function
and that automatically handles taking
and returning vector inputs
and yeah as a bonus you can see that
there is actually a built-in like
jacobian
function in jax which which you can then
apply on top of this
uh which will automatically give you the
jacobian so like
uh gradient functions for each element
in the batch
uh this usually makes the testing much
cleaner as well
uh for example because you don't have to
worry about
this like vectorization like
broadcasting manually
um since it will all be taken care of by
the
by the vmap uh yeah so
i think that's all from me so thank you
very much for your attention
and i think june will now talk about
meta gradients
yeah thanks uh so hi everyone i'm june
i'm going to
um briefly talk about how we use jacks
for
our recent work on discovering the
important learning algorithms
so if you go to the next slide
so in this project we wanted to meta
learn
an entire reinforcement learning update
rule
from a distribution of agents and
distribution of environments
but there were several technical
challenges in this project
that people next so first of all we
wanted to simulate many independent
learning agents where
each agent is interacting with its own
set of environments
this is already quite unusual because
normally in reinforcement learning we
we consider just one learning agent but
we wanted to simulate many different
agents in this
framework but at the same time we wanted
to apply
the same update rule which is the meta
learner in this case across
four different learning agents in a
synchronized way
and also we wanted to calculate the meta
gradient
over the update procedure which requires
calculating the second order
gradient and finally we also wanted to
massively scale up this approach
by increasing the number of learning
agents without
introducing any extra calls
so to tackle all these challenges we
first
implemented all the environments in
jacks and we first implemented
a single update rule single agent and
single jacks environment
interaction as you can see from this
figure
and then in the next slide we we added
a free map over the environments
to implement multiple environments
interacting with
a single agent and if you go to the next
slide
we then added another remap at the
outer scope to simulate multiple
independent learning agents and each
agent still has
their own set of environments and
finally if you go to the next slide we
added a pmap over the entire computation
graph
to implement the same competition graph
across many different gpu cores and
distribute this competition graph
still
all of these cpu cores have a single
shared global update group but they all
simulate
their own set of agents and own set of
environments
so if you go to the next slide
this is the pseudocode of our framework
so the top part
implements the agent update and the
bottom part
implements the meta gradient calculation
and these three maps and pmaps the
yellow parts are essentially the b maps
and p maps that i
just described in the previous slides so
without these b-maps and p-maps
this pseudo code essentially implements
a single agent
single update for single environment
interaction
but by just adding a few remaps and
pmaps we were
actually able to massively scale up the
approach
so in the actual experiment we used 16
core
tpu and using this we were able to
simulate
1000 parallel running agents and 60 000
parallel environments
with a single global shared update guru
and
also we were able to process more than 3
million steps per second
which was amazing for us
so if you go to the next slide
yeah to just summarize that we basically
had
several challenges including you know
simulating multiple agents and
calculating meta gradient and so on
but by using jazz we were actually able
to handle
all these challenges quite easily
without putting
much engineering effort and also um
out of this project we also metal learn
uh
quite interesting reinforcement learning
optical out of
you know many agents and many
environments and you can maybe check out
the paper if you are
interested so yeah that's um that's all
we have for today so if you have any
questions we will
take the questions yeah
thank you so much super interesting we
had a lot of
conversations in comments and feedback
in the chat i
will read a bit out to you first of all
just someone
said wow i think this use case really
highlights the abstraction of vmap and
pmap
and and super interesting to see how by
using it you can
scale up to a thousand agents so super
impressive
there was also lots of love for for the
ecosystem
and the libraries a lot of good feedback
on that
um we have a question if the if the code
is shared if it's open
um if you are asking about the final
project that i
just described unfortunately the code is
not
public yet so it actually requires a bit
of you know
open sourcing process to be able to
share but
yeah i guess i think there is a like a
public
implementation by someone else maybe you
can check out is it planned to do open
source or
not yet um for now we don't have a
specific plan for that
so but um i guess we are basically
continuing this
effort so is
at some point we might be able to um
open source our implementation
and there was one question maybe going
back to to the more kind of initial
uh part of the talk um
someone asked if uh yeah after after
like um
loving the the ecosystem and the
libraries and looking at this if there
are any plans for an api
or a kind of conceptual harmonization
between haiku and flax
that's a great question um i
don't really know but the fact is that
these two libraries were
developed independently in the early
days of jax
so i think they
should be interoperable in some sense
but i haven't checked it so you can tell
for sure
say for sure
yeah subtext works with that that's true
optics works with
everything that represents parameters as
trees of tenders
that jax also allows for an
entertainment with ml ir
um i don't know
can can say
need to check this
do we have any other questions for the
speakers
yeah it was mostly a lot of like uh i
don't know if you had time like to have
a quick look at the chat but
a lot of like um funny
and and uh great feedback and back and
forth
um yeah maybe a last last comment if the
slides will be shared
or or for the links
in the papers
um i need to check in with
the best person of contact from deepmind
that is um
no problem but i can definitely share
yeah sounds great i'll definitely share
maybe some some of the papers as links
maybe later on
in the chat and on slack and yeah
definitely check out check out the
libraries um
[Music]
perfect then um yeah somebody said when
the videos are up the slides will be
there so
so yeah the great great um kind of
um news is definitely that yeah
we we um
will be able to or hopefully we'll be
able to see the video later on
but yeah we're checking in for that as
well so please stay tuned
if we don't have any more questions
thank you so much for
for the talk this was really super great
to see how
the jax ecosystem is a deep mind and how
you're using it
so thank you so much really appreciate
it and i think it's time
to move on to the fourth talk um i hope
all of our speakers are there i think
i've seen them
unmute themselves and if you're ready
you can share your slides we have
uh sid joao and joanna from cohere today
and they will talk about
large language modeling
um yeah i think you're all here
no also sure perfect
yeah um joanna can you see the screen
yes uh sorry i'm trying
okay perfect uh hey um everyone thank
you for coming today
um we are very excited to share what we
are doing
and cohere and so today sid
draw and i are going to talk about
cohere's journey
on building a large scale language model
and how the recent development of dpuvm
and jax
led us to the improvement uh in our
model parallelism framework
so um before we start let me introduce
cohere
to you um we are an early stage startup
based
in toronto that builds large scale
language models
we're fairly new just around two years
old but we are
rapidly growing um with 30 people in our
team
and the first three over here are our
co-founders uh
aiden uh nick and ivan so
aiden nick are from google brain and
ivan was working on large-scale language
model like serving
around two years ago and um our mission
is to build
machines that understand the world and
to make them safely
accessible to all so specifically we are
focusing on building safe highly
scalable
and highly performant language models
that could easily be accessed
by our api endpoints so what that means
for us
for scalability the modeling team has
been working on creating a model
framework
called megazord so megazord is a model
parallelism framework
that distributes the model across
multiple devices
and the core idea behind this is the
pipeline parallelism
specifically g-pipe um
support those of you who aren't too
familiar with the pipeline parallelism
so um g-pipe is a model parallelism
technique
and multi-device setup where we break
down a batch
into multiple micro batches and send
those micro batches to the next device
so the device after doesn't need to wait
for the whole batch to be done
so for this diagram each row in the
diagram
like on top and bottom are the
individual devices
that can be run in parallel and the
squares here are the schedule
scheduled job for each micro batch
the diagram on the top describes and i
have modal parallelism
and the bottom one describes you pipe so
for the knight motor paralysis so
imagine you have a batch size of 32
so the f-zero here will um try to finish
the whole job of the 32
uh batch size and the
rest of the device will be idle waiting
for the first device to be done
and just only when the dirty uh two
batch size is done from the first device
it'll move on to the second and the
bottleneck
is still there all the way until the top
um
so for g pipe what happens is uh uh so
say you break it down to four micro
batches
so the first device will work on the
batch size of eight first and then we'll
pass this down to the second device
and while the second device is working
on the first
part of the batch um the first device is
also working on the first batch which is
the
second part of the first batch so while
doing that
um it reduces the bubble in the middle
like the bubble
actually means like the the idle time of
the device
and yeah um so if you mentioned the f0
on the top
being as long as the f-zero zero and
f-zero three combined
um you will see a considerable amount of
bubble in the
niagara model parallelism but g5
actually reduces it
and um this results in
the soft linear step time increase when
you have when you're increasing the
model
linearly so i'll i'll get the questions
from the
end but yeah going back to the megazord
uh
we placed each uh tpu on separate
processes
and piped the activations and
ingredients so as an early start edge
startup
we mainly used tpu v38s often
preemptable ones
because we wanted to scale up the model
while being cost aware
and for the context we did not have a
tpu vm as our option last year
so our initial stack included regular
tpu nodes out tensorflow 2
and python multiprocessing library
so for us not having dpvm was a very big
deal
because uh it meant that we did not have
direct access to
communication between tpus and all the
tensor um
communication had to pass through our
host machine
so a forward pass looks something like
this so the first tpu
would process the first micro batch
it'll send it to the host machine and
the host machine will acknowledge
uh the activation and it'll send it to
the second tpu for the next
um
propagation and the backward pass looks
very similar
um it will uh it just flows the other
way around
the last tpu will get the loss and
gradients
from the last cpu it gets sent back to
the host machine and the host machine
will send it to the second best
and yes we personify tpu and cohere
um yeah so uh for us um
this this is what we call um megazord
version one
and megazoryv1 allowed us to scale up
our model size
and build a product around this but um
it has some major drawbacks that you saw
earlier so the biggest one was this
double communication
where which drastically increased the
communication
so we were spending way too much time on
communication and
this bottleneck limited us from
effectively scaling up
also there were a lot of manual tensor
handling since
um a multi-processing library was very
low level
uh for us and pretty much everything
needed to be
handled by cues so now i'm gonna pass
this to
set so that you can talk about the
version 2.
um thanks for that joanna and uh
so yeah so megazord v2 um
we really wanted to cut down on the
communication cost we had to pay
in v1 because uh like joanna mentioned
we it was really preventing us from
scaling up
or getting to the scale that we wanted
to get to so
with the advent of tpu vms and uh and by
using grey that really
improved the com the spend time in
communication and we have we spent less
time for each step
compared to megazord v1 because what tpu
vms enabled for us
was tpu to tpu communication like
directly transferring activations and
gradients
between tpus because tpu i can just spin
up a ray cluster
and make my host machine the head node
and the tpu vms are the
child nodes and they just communicate
with each other without having to go
through the host machine all the time
and this communication cost reduction uh
was uh was really helpful
uh in scaling up and the queue handling
became a lot more
simplified because we did not uh
need to explicitly handle all these
transfers
all the pre-processing post-processing
associated with
transfers from ppo device tpu node to
host machine
and now with tpu vms and ray that became
like
much more like uh simpler uh one thing
to note is that we were still using
uh megazord v2 uh with g-pipe
so which means that if you go back
there's still this bubble where your tpu
cores are
have an idle time they're doing nothing
in this bubble stage
so so with pipeline parallelism
we were getting the scale that we wanted
to
but the code utilization is one aspect
that we wanted to improve
upon and and the training
looked something like this in megazord
v2 where like uh
the host machine sends the input to the
let's let's say you have 16
uh layers and four devices you can split
up these 16 layers into
four chunks of four layers each and
place them on each device
dpi one has the first four tpu as the
second four and so on
so the input gets sent to dpo1 and the
process under the output
from the first four layers and the
activations go to tpo2
and they just directly talk to each
other and tpu4 evaluates the loss and
just sends it back
computes the gradients and you just keep
computing the gradients until tp1 and
send it back
to host machine for metrics or for
whatever
checkpoint and whatever you want to do
after each uh train step
so we basically have the communication
time because there was no longer the
host interference in each and every
uh tensor transfer stage
so so with this in mind like
given the context of megazord v1 and
megazord v2
uh we were really all we already started
thinking about
the next generation of megazord and what
we needed in the next generation
and one thing was mesh level parallelism
that we were really excited about
uh if you were here for ben stock
earlier he mentioned
his mesh transformer work also uh
uses uh mesh level parallelism and this
is appealing to us because
even though in megazord v2 we had re and
tpu vms
these are individual different machines
like tpu vms
and the communication was still it
wasn't negligible cost
and with tpu pod slices you have
multiple tpu vms
that are actually connected to each
other uh in a grid like structure
so which means that your communication
time is much much
lesser because they're actually
physically connected
and we wanted to take advantage of the
smash level parallelism and
if you weren't there for the talk uh one
one sentence description could be
if you have a grid of devices and you
have to access x and y
could be a z axis but as well but for
now if you have x and y axis
and on the x-axis you can have model
level parallelism and on the y-axis you
can have data level parallelism
so what this ensures is that here all of
your cores
in this grid of tpu devices are being
utilized
uh all the time so there's very minimal
uh there's little to no idle time in
this uh
uh mesh level uh parallelism
and it and one thing was
since microsoft v1 and v2 were using
tensorflow 2.0
and the only thing that we were familiar
with it was
mesh tensorflow which provided the
provided
mesh abstractions so that we can
implement this
but the issue was mesh tensorflow
primarily worked with tensorflow 1
and node 2.0 and integrating it into a
code base that we were already
working on was very challenging and
so we ruled out mesh tensorflow as an
option and we started looking towards
other things and in the next generation
we also wanted to alleviate
communication costs by taking advantage
of match level parallelism and tpu pod
slices
and long term scalability so by
our learnings from v1 and v2 uh and when
we
implement v3 what and what we have in
mind is
making this framework uh relatively
future proof
so we do not want to keep suffering
these communication costs and
all of the latency issues that come with
v1 and v2 so
keeping that in mind was really
important to us so that we can
get to scale get a scale as much as we
need
without being bottlenecked by any kind
of communication issues
or infrastructure issues and
another super important thing for us was
the barrier to entry should be super low
and what i mean by that is at go here we
have megazord team which focuses on
scaling up
and the modeling team which focuses on
like uh trying
new experiments and uh ideas and stuff
so so we want the barrier between these
two teams to be as low
as possible if someone from modeling
team wants to get into
a scaling up and contribute some
some code to it or some new
functionality to it we really wanted to
make it as easy as possible
but with v1 and v2 that was not the case
because you have the
tensorflow has kind of a complicated at
least our experience has been
a bit uh it's kind of obfuscated
abstractions with ppe cluster resolver
and dpu like and
basically it's not easy to work with and
it's not very straightforward so we
wanted to
when deciding about the next generation
we wanted to choose a framework that's
that makes things as simple and as
intuitive as possible
and with jack's it's cheesy but it was
love at first sight
because it gives us a sense of
familiarity uh
and chance is very much like numpy but
with autodesk
and when we are writing out a new
framework that sense of
familiarity can really accelerate the
development process and which was really
important to us
and i'll leave it to joao to talk more
about jacks and flax and
what we're doing with that at cohere and
okay so yeah uh jacksonville flags and
why is it good first of all it's very
easy to convert to
code to tags and in fact it's just that
it's easy in general to code injects you
you can get a lot done with very few
lines of code
and so the whole like um migration
process that's generally pretty painful
is being sweet and nice
so yeah easy to work with we have vmap
that makes a lot of
code much simpler we have the
compositional transformations with just
a better way to code in general a better
way to
model your stuff we have grad vjp
and jvp which are like vector jacobian
products
and the opposite so now we can get
gradients with respect to different
function arguments in a very intuitive
and very simple way
and that's again useful when you're
trying to do this
this pipeline parallelism and it's also
useful
to write more complex optimization
methods so
second degree optimization like shampoo
that or
and you talked about yesterday adversary
optimization
it's an area that's growing and that's
showing like amazing results like the
berto
also more and more papers are
implemented in jacks each day
and right now we i mean not right now
but
until a while ago we would have to
translate every paper that was
implemented in jax to tensorflow and
everything i thought was permitted by
toroshu
tensorflow and that was pretty hard and
now at least the new papers and jacks we
can pretty much
just grab the code and test it in our
code base to see
how it plays with stuff and all of that
means that experimentation is now much
easier
coding is much easier and the mali and
the modeling team is happy
and pass aside please okay
now we also see that data parallelism
with pmap
is very easy it's pretty much plug and
play
we have fidget and x map which batman
showed which allows us to do sharding
again very easily almost plug and play
this one is slightly more complex
but again it's much easier than
what we have with tensorflow or even
pytorch
we have a much better integration with
xla and with tpus which
will help us in general gets better car
utilization which will reduce the
communication costs considerably
but all of those things they're really
amazing but the thing is
okay are we what are we losing and in
fact we're not losing much because with
jax utf
we can still use all of our pipeline our
old code base for serving models so
we're not
we we are getting the benefits of a
better way to represent
our ideas while still having all of the
amazing testosterone survey ecosystem
and there's just great support we have
the tpu chats which are the
checks and flags folks are always
answering any questions we have
and all of that ends up making the mega
13 happy
and now it will show you a small
proof of concept of using tracks and how
to how you do
break down models for pipelining
yeah um so this is really a tough
example i know everyone
uh everyone's participating everyone
participating in this community even
it's getting a they're getting a v38 so
if you wanted to do
uh this pipeline parallelism or even
just
splitting model across devices uh i just
wanted to show
a toy example for a representation
purposes it works
but we're just working working with v38
under the pretense of like
working with multiple devices so uh
let's just
see how that looks and uh it's gonna be
nice okay uh
yeah um can you guys see this and
should i just zoom in or does this mind
i think it would be great if you could
zoom in just a bit perfect
is this better yeah thanks okay
all right um so with jackson plaques
it's really easy to kind of emulate
this uh distributed model behavior and
that's what we're going to look at right
now um
and even when i was writing the story
notebook i was surprised at
how simple it really was to kind of get
this example going
uh so let's take a look and firstly it's
just
the normal imports you import flags and
fluxes are neutral network modules and
jacks and opt x
uh we are using optics for our
optimization
uh and we got a link to the notebook um
sure uh
i'll share it right after this this
demonstration
and with h params you just said set up
the learning rate bath size hidden size
and all of these things
and for the here uh number of model
partitions
so what we're doing here is we're trying
to split up six layers
into three devices so each device has
two layers each keep in mind that we are
still using a v38
but i'm just using this for
representational purposes uh
where i'm referring to multiple devices
so
you'll see things will get clearer in a
bit but basically you have three model
partitions
and six layers in total but spread
across three devices with two layers
each on
each device and
you're kind of loading this eminence
data set for classification and the
model class
i mean flux actually provides an mlp but
i'm just writing this out
and just to be more explicit
um so your mlb is a data class again
because n dot modules are and you're
defining the number of layers and in the
call function you're basically defining
the layer as well as calling it uh with
the compact decorator which is
really which really makes the code
simpler
uh to read and use
and yeah unless it's the last layer you
want to have a dense layer
and create an optimizer
use addon and you want to initialize
your
optimizer state and optimizer update
functions you wanted it on that
and uh that's all objects
and in the setup function you're
basically returning the model parameters
and the
optimizer states and updates associated
with that network
and what network is is here so firstly
we set up a distributed model
um
so yeah so there are three partitions
and for each partition we create a new
network
and that's the mlp and
we clear this network get the optimizer
states updates and
like the parameters and maintain that in
a list
and and you also set up a single model
we are setting up a single model because
we want to kind of benchmark this
distributed model with a single model
and by single model i mean since in the
distributed model you have six layers
spread across three divisors the single
module is just
six layers as a single model uh just to
you know kind of
uh benchmark it make sure that there's
nothing going wrong
and this is all general stuff you
standardize your data
and you have your metrics function and
okay
for the distributed func network we have
forward and backward functions
and we need two separate functions
because for the forward function it's
just as simple as calling the
network.apply function
that your flax module has and the
backward function
actually needs to call network.apply
again because
you have multiple batches that you're
piping through these partitions
and the activations are not cached so
what you want to do is reconstruct those
activations
and then do the backward propagation
and because these are because we are
representing these three partitions as
three divisors
you need to take the output gradients
from the loss and get it to the
third device and third device returns
the activation gradient
gradients with respect to activations
again which need to be sent to the
second device
and the second device needs to look at
these gradients
and needs to look at the activations
that were produced by the current patch
and reproduce the gradients within those
partitions hopefully that makes sense
what i'm saying
but in tensorflow what you would do is
you would call tf.gradients
with an argument that's referred to as
output gradients
so you take output gradients and
pass it to t of tau gradients and with
jacks you have
vjp that really simplifies things
and what it returns is the activations
the uh
the output of the network.apply which is
the activations and
the vjp function itself and the vgp
function if you
once you pass the output gradients you
get you get the
gradients with respect to the parameters
in that partition and the gradients that
you need to send
to the previous partition and so you
return all of these things
and you define the loss function that's
all the normal stuff
and now here you're defining kind of the
activation caches
and you're calling forward functions and
jacks.value.grad kind of
you're just differentiating the cross
entropy loss and getting the output
gradient
and and this is basically the backward
pass
so you're calling backward and all of
this is handled in the backward function
we saw earlier
where the output gradients are just
being chained together and they're
being sent across all the partitions
and by indexing the right partition you
can just apply your updates locally to
each partition
once you have the gradients ready for
the parameters with respect with the
gradients with respect to those
parameters in each partition
and the single model train is basically
training the
six six-layer single model uh like
in the just simpler jacks way you call
just for
a value and grab and you call it on the
loss function which is just calling and
apply
and uh you apply updates it's as simple
as that
for distributed model because we needed
to reconstruct the activations and
handle
the gradient our computation we needed
like a backward function
but for single module we don't and this
is all just the training
normal training loop stuff where you
report the metrics evaluate on the test
set etc
and you can see that as you train
you basically have very similar
performance for distributed model
and the single model uh
so that kind of ensures that there's no
bugs here there's nothing going wrong
and it's so this is just a super short
collab
that kind of emulates this distributed
model uh setting
and i think it really drives home like
how easy it is to write things
and jackson plaques um and implement
pipeline parallelism uh
yes the backward passes are done
sequentially across partitions so
partition three takes care of it then
partition two then partition one
yes and so yeah that's all we
have for you today and thanks for
listening uh to the talk and by the way
we are hiring so
if you're interested in joining us you
should shoot us an email
and there's also a level page uh that
you can find
uh find on the website uh and thank you
awesome thanks so much uh yeah cool to
see what you're working on let's go here
and
you just answered the last question uh
in in the chat and we have
i think one or two more uh more general
questions
um let's have a quick look
um i think two related questions maybe
um just very generally what is the text
that
you're using at right now at cohere and
which multiprocessing libraries in
particular
yeah so yeah we have a in-house um
data scraper and that uh filtration
method
so it's a clear text but yeah it's like
a
web script text that is filtered on the
toxicity and
um yeah and it's just a
bit more of a data like a pipeline but
yeah it's like a web script
in-house data for us
and multi-processing library is the
regular python
multi-person library that's got evolved
to the
the ray um
and i think i missed one one question
about like the gradient
accumulation and the sink so we use
something uh very similar
to hogwarts let me actually put it here
yeah so we will have like a call that
um ask each partition to sync
on the sync which means that oh like
just
um apply the accumulated guardians
and yeah
oh um yeah a lot of people asked if if
it's somehow possible to share the
collab
um and maybe the slides possible yeah
i'll be
putting the link in the chat right now
uh it's giving me like a few seconds
[Music]
let's see there's one question um if you
have some sort of
time based or a tick-tock clock
dynamics for sinking gradients before
accumulation
and the guesses if you're using ray for
this
yes uh yes this is the the um the
guardian accumulation and like of the
sync
part though we yeah we can use hogwarts
but if you like how well it's like hard
to
implement what you can do is you can
just count the number of
um micro batches and so when when you're
done with like the full batch then you
can
um yeah you can implement it so that
it applies the gradients at that point
so it doesn't really have to be time but
it's
i think um
yes and
there were like uh there were questions
of worsted
about the background passes um this is
the part where
we implement cheap pipes so in real life
we would actually place
each photo partition to be in separate
processes
so it doesn't necessarily mean it has to
be
executed um or sequentially
[Music]
and which resources helped you alone
help your people on jack's flex menu
so i really want to emphasize how
amazing the support for jackson plucks
is
and we were talking to the flax team uh
the other day
and we really got insights into
they really helped helped us choose
between okay do you want to use period
or do you want to use xmap or
what kind of um
like how would you go about jacks and
any kind of debugging issues they've
been super responsive and helpful so
i think and the jacks docs are amazing
that
i i wouldn't be exaggerating if i said
if it's like it's the best aux for
like 10 like our machine learning day
screen works for jax
and uh i'm really happy with the support
we've been getting on that end
so yeah yeah some more
specific points i guess there's the jax
uh series of tutorials by deepmindfox
it's in the jacks documentation
and for flag specifically well flux has
some pretty nice documentations
and the how-to's showing how to use more
advanced
features so i think these are the the
main sources that
like would get would help you hit the
ground run